the first money that the embassy brought
to me the first thing I did was get a
guitar for $50 America that guitar saved
my life the big boss of the pavilion
he saw me with the guitar and he said
you come here
and I went into his cell
he said play so I pull out my guitar and
start to play
I became the big boss's musician and
from then on everybody knew that I was
under the protection of him
but I had to become a different person I
had to become one of them
they gave me a large 45 and I had to
stand guard duty
on the walls everywhere were smeared
handprints in blood there's a streak of
blood on the floor there were they had
dragged a body out the worst thing I saw
was watching a man dying
they shot a man at point-blank range and
then stabbed him five times to make sure
they finished the job
when I was just barely holding myself
together trying just to keep from
breaking down crying
but then I have to push it away because
I'm gonna go either crazy or have a
complete breakdown
I would rather die than to go through
see the things I saw